on a tendance à associer de
l'intelligence à la logique pure comme
si pour bien adressé un problème
il suffisait d'effectuer un raisonnement
déductif qui ne repose jamais sur des
mots mal défini et n'accepte que des
liens de causalité clairement vrai sauf
que cette prévalence de la logique pose
quatre problèmes le premier problème
comme on en a parlé dans notre série sur
l'infini et comme monsieur fille en a
parlé dans deux trois quatre cinq mots
disons un épisode pour un certain anti
naturel aide c'est que la logique n'a
rien d'évident et posent de nombreuses
difficultés comme le tri même taclé pas
l'inévitabilité de définition circulaire
où la quasi impossibilité dénoncé des
axiomes clairement vrai bref la logique
c'est compliqué et quand vous dites à
quelqu'un que son raisonnement est
illogique j'ai envie de dire un
raisonnement logique ça ressemble à ça
et j'ai jamais vu de tels raisonnements
dans les commentaires youtube soit on
est mauvais logicien mais supposons que
par un coup de baguette magique ou
devient tout à coup des experts de la
logique on tombe alors sur le deuxième
problème
la science n'est pas qu'une déduction
logique pour effectuer des prédictions
il nous faut deviner les lois de la
physique
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'induction et
de nombreux ouvrages peu conclusif ont
été écrits à ce sujet mais soit
supposons que par un deuxième coup de
baguette magique devient tout à coup des
experts de l'induction si bien que l'on
arrive à déterminer très précisément les
lois physiques de l'univers et oublions
les bizarreries quantique pour
simplifier est ce qu il nous suffirait
alors d'être logique pour connaître
notre univers et effectuer des
prédictions selon le géant pierre simon
laplace bon mathématicien préférées il
ne manquerait qu'une seule chose à
savoir la connaissance de l'état
physique actuelle de notre univers je
cite une intelligence qui un instant
donné connaîtrait toutes les forces dont
la nature est animée et la situation
respective des êtres qui la composent
si d'ailleurs elle était suffisamment
vaste pour soumettre ces données à
l'analyse en pra seraient dans la même
formule
les mouvements des plus grands corps de
l'univers et ceux du plus légères at
home rien ne serait incertain pour elle
et l'avenir comme le passé serait
présent à ses yeux et cette citation
célèbre a conduit beaucoup de
mathématiciens de philosophes et de
scientifiques a pensé qu'il suffisait de
déterminer les lois physiques de
l'univers et de déterminer l'état
physique
actuelle de l'univers pour en prédire
l'avenir mais on tombe alors sur un
troisième problème toute mesure est
bourré de petites erreurs or la théorie
du chaos dont j'ai brièvement parlé chez
docteur norman affirme que toute petite
erreur dans les conditions initiales
peut conduire à des prédictions
extrêmement erronée
soit mais supposons que par un troisième
coup de baguette magique ou parviennent
à accéder à l'état physique exact de
l'univers et bien même la même avec les
lois et les états physiques exact de
l'univers et même avec une logique sans
faille il demeurerait très impossible
d'effectuer une prédiction quelconque et
ça alan turing l'a compris avant tout le
monde dans son merveilleux article de
1950 il écrit l'idée que les machines ne
peuvent pas conduire à des surprises est
une conséquence je crois d'un sophisme
fallacieux auquel les philosophe et
mathématicien sont particulièrement
sujets il s'agit de l'hypothèse selon
laquelle dès qu'un fait et présenter un
esprit toutes les conséquences de ce
fait saute immédiatement à l'esprit de
celui ci cette hypothèse est très utile
dans certains cas mais on oublie trop
facilement qu'elle peut être fausse
autrement dit selon turing certains
calculs sont nécessairement terriblement
l'on y compris pour le plus génial d
esprit dont la mécanique interne serait
optimisé pour effectuer ces calculs et
en particulier dans le cas de pierre
simon voilà je les aime tellement que
j'appelle persimmon calculer des
prédictions à partir des lois et des
états physiques de l'univers pourrait
être que 10 est inéluctablement un
calcul terriblement long si l'on
qu'aucun humain ni machine ne peut
l'effectuer avant la nuit des temps seul
un démon parfois appelée démons de la
place qui serait ni homme ni machines
petit parvenir et pour bien illustrer
cela intéressons nous à des univers dont
on connaît parfaitement les lois
physiques et dont on peut choisir les
états physiques à savoir les automates
cellulaires l'automate cellulaire le
plus connu est le jeu de la vie de
conway que david a présenté dans une
vidéo sur science étonnante cet automate
est un quadrillage de cellules qui
peuvent être noire ou blanche et en gros
une cellule de t'avoir juste le bon
nombre de cellules voisines noir pour
devenir ou rester noir je vous renvoie
vers la vidéo de david pour les détails
ce n'est pas ce qui m'intéresse
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la condition
initiale à 4,52 la vidéo haut niveau à
cinq cellules noir dans un océan de
cellules blanche on a là une situation
on en connaît parfaitement l'état
présent de l'univers et où l'on connaît
parfaitement les lois physiques de
l'univers quel en sera l'évolution
vous voyez bien que cette question n'est
qu'une question de logique mais c'est
une prédiction qui échappent très
largement à ceux d'entre nous qui
n'avons pas pris le temps de demander la
réponse à une machine et ça c'est parce
que l'évolution ne se stabilise qu'après
un peu plus de 1000 libération alors oui
si vous étiez motivé dans ce cas vous
auriez peut-être pu faire le calcul à la
main mais c'est parce qu'il s'agit là
d'un cas trivial et oui l'état physique
initial n'a que cinq cellules noir
par opposition notre univers physique
lui est formidablement plus sophistiqué
que ce soit à l'échelle planétaire
biologique chimique ou même à l'échelle
des particules élémentaires
typiquement un verre d'eau contient
environ 10 puissance 23 particules pour
avoir une complexité comparables l'état
initial du jeu de la vie devrait avoir
10 puissance 23 cellule noir or 10
puissance 23 c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus que 5 10 puissance 23
c'est même largement trop pour les
machines d'aujourd'hui
et oui la capacité de stockage de votre
ordinateur ce contenu tera octets ce qui
correspond à environ seulement 10
puissance 12 bits d'information même
toute l'information de tout internet ne
représenterait que quelques états octets
soit environ 10 puissance 21 bits
d'information pire encore si l'on veut
prédire le futur dans un an
en suivant mécaniquement les lois de
l'univers nous faut calculer tous les
pas de temps hors des théories physiques
suggère que le temps avancerait de
manière discrète au rythme de 10
puissance 43 pas de temps par seconde
pour prédire le futur dans un an il
faudrait effectuer 10 puissance 50
étapes de calcul or nos ordinateurs ont
une vitesse de calcul de l'ordre du
gigahertz soit 10 puissance 9 calculs
par seconde
simuler le futur à 1 en prendrait 10
puissance 34 années soit des milliards
de milliards de milliards de fois plus
que l'âge de l'univers
autant dire qu'avec la technologie
moderne même si l'on connaissait les
lois et l'état physique de l'univers la
meilleure façon d'en prédire l'avenir à
coup sûr et de très loin c'est tout
bêtement d'attendre que l'avenir sur
vienne bon ok mais c'est peut-être parce
qu'on est des mauvaises ingénieurs
peut-être que les ingénieurs du futur e
seront capables de concevoir des
machines qui sont effectivement capable
de prédire l'avenir
cette réflexion nous amène en fait à une
question plus fondamentale qui consiste
à se demander si l'intérieur d'un
système physique peut prédire son futur
avant que le futur n'advienne après de
longues réflexions
l'informaticien stephen wolfram dont
david a parlé à la fin de sa vidéo a
fini par postuler ce qu'il a appelé
l'irréductibilité algorithmique de façon
grossière
celle ci revient à dire qu'étant donné
un état initial aléatoire d'un automate
non trivier
disons un automate turing complet alors
la seule façon de prédire le futur aide
entièrement le simuler autrement dit
selon walf rames étant donné ce qu'il se
passe dans une pièce close
il serait en général impossible de
copier coller toute l'information à
l'intérieur de la pièce
et de prédire son état un an plus tard
avec l'information copier coller à moins
d'effectuer un calcul qui de toute façon
à l'inter de cet univers physique mais
très de façon théorique au moins un
enfant a terminé voilà qui me semble
être un argument assez fatale ou pure
réductionnisme c'est à dire à l'
approche purement logique qui ne
jurerait que par les lois fondamentales
de la physique certes savoir que la
physique
à notre échelle émergent loi
fondamentale c'est bien à l'instar de la
thèse de church turing ou des lois de la
thermodynamique ça permet de fixer des
limites sur ce qui peut et ne peut pas
arriver dans notre univers
cependant déduire le futur de ces lois
fondamentales
quand bien même toutes les données
nécessaires sera à notre disposition
c'est très très très illusoire pour
effectuer les prédictions
il est alors utile d'oublier les
paradigmes fondamentaux et d'utiliser un
langage plus macroscopique et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait david
regardez là autour de la 70e génération
ce truc c'est ce qu'on appelle un
planeur sommes regardés y en ad'autres
ici le planeur c'est une structure qui
change de forme mais tous les quatre
tours retrouve sa configuration en
s'étant déplacé d'une case en diagonale
on peut en voir d'autres un peu plus
tard dans la simulation et du coup c'est
une structure qui avance alors ça paraît
assez triviale comme observation mais
c'est en fait assez étrange est génial
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que david a arrêté de parler de cases
blanches ou noires et s'est mis à part
les deux structures
autrement dit il a abandonné la rigueur
de la description microscopiques et a
choisi d'adopter un langage
macroscopique pourtant complètement
absent des lois fondamentales
or ce n'est pas si triviale que ce
langage macroscopique soit 6 adéquat
après tout d'un point de vue
microscopique clients ne se déplacent
tout ce qu'il ya ce sont des cases
noires et blanches qui s'éteignent et
s'allume voilà qui n'est pas sans
rappeler la possibilité de concevoir des
structures qui vont plus vite que la
vitesse de la lumière comme celle dont
par derek miller sur veritas yonne
par ok mais si le spot lumineux qui se
déplacent n'est qu'une illusion en quoi
la structure de david n'en est elle pas
une elle aussi et si le spot lumineux
est une illusion
est ce qu'on a le droit de parler de
spots lumineux si vous voyez un spot
lumineux aller plus vite que la vitesse
de la lumière
auriez-vous tort de dire que vous voyez
un spot lumineux aller plus vite que la
vitesse de la lumière
ça serait bizarre de s'interdire de
parler de spots lumineux tout comme il
serait étrange de s'interdire de parler
de planeur dans le jeu de la vie en fait
ce qui est important de noter c'est que
les descriptions macroscopique de
l'univers peuvent aisément donné lieu à
un vocabulaire flou voire inexistantes
dans les lois et les états physiques
fondamentaux de l'univers
oui parce que le concept de structure
david l'utilisent sans l'avoir défini et
il ya une bonne raison à cela
je prétends qu'il est impossible de
donner une définition au mot structure
avec laquelle on sera tous d'accord et
pour ceux qui ne me crois pas je vous
invite à essayer de mettre une
définition du mot structure dans les
commentaires ci dessous
mais le plus étonnant est le plus
important c'est que même si david n'a
pas défini le mot structure on est tous
plus ou moins d'accord sur ce qu'il veut
à peu près dire par là de même quand on
voit cette image n'est pas déraisonnable
de penser que le chat veut manger la
souris alors que ni le chat ni la syrie
ni la volonté du chat ne sont des
concepts présents dans les lois
fondamentales de la théorie quantique
des champs
et puis si vous y réfléchissez les
concepts de chat de souris et de volonté
du chat c'est horriblement difficile à
définir
la deuxième chose étrange est génial
dans la remarque de david sait que le
langage macroscopique permet des
prédictions quand bien même les lois
fondamentales nous serait inconnu alors
dit comme ça ça peut vous paraître
scandaleusement anti scientifique mais
regardez ce canon un planeur 60 p 5 h 2
0 il ne semble pas débile de prédire que
le canon continuera à propulser des
planeurs identique et intervalles de
temps réguliers même sans suivre les
détails des calculs du canon alors oui
le canon a été conçu et choisi pour que
cette régularité émergent mais même si
vous ne le saviez pas surtout si vous
observez le canon propulser des planeurs
pendant
il serait assez insensé de ne pas au
moins un peu généralisés la régularité
des planeurs expulsé alors oui je suis
sûr que parmi vous il ya des logiciens
puristes qui vont dire que toute
généralisation de la sorte est purement
illogique
et c'est justement là où je veux en
venir on peut prédire de manière
illogique
mieux encore il faut prédire de manière
y compris lorsque l'on connaît pourtant
les lois et les états physiques exact de
l'univers parce qu'encore une fois
prédire de manière purement logique ça
nécessite des calculs beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop long pour votre cerveau
comme pour votre machine
d'ailleurs le genre de généralisation
que l'on vient de faire est ce que font
les scientifiques à longueur de journée
ils observent des choses se répéter et
ils postulent qu'elles continueront à se
répéter
même s'ils ne comprennent pas tous les
mécanismes sous jacents et c'est normal
que l'on se restreignent à faire cela
d'autant que le monde physique est
autrement plus complexe que le jeu de la
vie et les configurations qu'on en a vu
dans la vidéo de david
il a suffi de structures de quelques
dizaines de cellules pour que l'on soit
complètement perdu dans les calculs de
leur évolution et qu'on se contente
d'une description macroscopique des
structures mais surtout ces structures
évoluer sur des échelles de temps
raisonnable au plus de l'ordre de
quelques milliers d'itérations quelques
milliers d'itérations a contrario dans
l'univers physique le plus court
intervalle de temps mesuré à ce jour se
comptent en dizaines d' attoseconde soit
environ 10 puissance moins 17 secondes
si on suppose que l'univers avance au
rythme d'un calcul poulets temps de
planck c'est-à-dire un calcul tout les
10 puissance 43 secondes
voilà qui signifie que nous n'avons
jamais observé les faits de moins de 10
puissance 26 étapes de calcul de notre
univers hors caisse puis sens 26 étapes
de calcul c'est énorme
un ordinateur moderne mais très l'âge de
l'univers pour effectuer ce calcul
autant dire que toutes les lois de la
physique connu à ce jour échoue
complètement à décrire les calculs
élémentaires de notre univers et se
contentent nécessairement de décrire des
régularités qui émerge après 10
puissance beaucoup étape de calcul
autrement dit toute notre science y
compris toute notre physique n'est qu'un
ensemble de théories émergentes
les puristes y verront une critique des
sciences mais ce n'est pas du tout là où
je veux en venir
ce qu'il faut constater c'est que c'est
ce qu'il nous faut
1 encore une fois les lois physiques
fondamentales sont très incapable de
prédire des phénomènes à l'échelle
macroscopique car elle nécessite des
temps de calcul complètement irréaliste
ce dont on a besoin ce sont deux
théories émergentes dont le domaine de
validité sera nécessairement limitée et
dont les prédictions ne seront pas
entièrement fiable mais au moins ces
prédictions seront calculable en temps
raisonnable et en particulier à l'instar
de ce qu'on avait déjà conclu dans
l'épisode 4 pour des raisons pourtant
très différentes
il ne semble pas pertinent de juger la
vérité des théories ce qui semble plus
pertinent c'est d'en juger la
crédibilité et l'utilité laser fois j'ai
parlé de l'émergence de l'intelligence
et j'ai été très clair sur la manière
dont la pensée al khwarizmi qui dote
d'une neuvième siècle permet de rendre
quelque chose du 16e siècle un peu
triviale
en fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup plus à
dire il ya des raccourcis dans les
vidéos précédentes notamment la
résolution des équations du troisième et
du quatrième degré a eu lieu en italie
au xvième siècle notamment grâce à
tartaglia et d'autres comme cardan et
ferrari alors il y aurait beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire en fait une
histoire absolument fabuleuse derrière
tout ça qui mériterait peut-être un film
au cinéma notamment d histoire de
trahison et de promesses et tout ça
paraît malheureusement à notre
connaissance aucun youtuber nom n'a
encore parlé du coup je peux pas vous
voyez quelque chose mais c'est une
histoire qu'il faudra compter vous
voulez vraiment emprunter du doigt dans
l'épisode précédent c'est le fait que la
pensée al khwarizmi temps à décomposer
les méthodes de résolution est en fait
au 16e siècle est une méthode de
résolution des équations du troisième du
quatrième degré qui ont été proposées et
à partir du moment où cette méthode de
résolution était connue résoudre les
équations correspondait uniquement à
suivre des étapes les instructions qui
était du coup pas fourni par al
khwarizmi mais par les descendants de
crédit c'est-à-dire tartaglia la
compagnie et du coup résoudre de tels
équation correspondait uniquement à
effectuer des étapes de calcul les
étapes de quelqu un peu bizarre parce
qu'elles font intervenir notamment les
nombres imaginaire mais ça ne reste que
des étapes de calcul et du coup ces
équations aujourd'hui on peut les
résoudre uniquement vient le calcul
emmanuel de mer le fait remarquer qu'en
fait galilée surtout torricelli sont en
fait plutôt du xviie que du 16ème siècle
culpa c'est pourquoi j'ai commis
l'erreur de parler devant d'autorité en
vidéo président je crois que j'aime bien
ses moustaches de rigueur jp 06 dr fait
remarquer que la curiosité est une
partie importante de l'intelligence et
du coup on peut se demander si les
machines sont capables d'être curieuse
et réponse est oui en fait c'est pas si
difficile il suffit de mettre dans la
fonction publique et de la machine
l'envi de mieux comprendre le monde qui
les entoure est temps d'aller chercher
les données qui vont lui permettre
d'améliorer sa propre intelligence
artificielle notamment il ya tout un
champ de recherche qui s'appelle active
learning qui cherche justement à
optimiser ce processus de quête
d'informations hannibal a team nous
demande si c'est pas un peu simpliste de
réduire l'intelligence à une multitude
d'opérations c'est parce que j'ai dit
dans l'épisode précédent
ce sur quoi je voulais vraiment insister
c'est le fait que pour faire émerger de
l'intelligence à partir uniquement de
calcul effectué un grand nombre des
tables de calcul était une condition qui
semblait nécessaire et en particulier je
voulais insister sur un sophisme qui est
souvent présent qui est le fait que
lorsqu'on observe un truc on se dit
qu'il est bête parce que on observe
juste quelques étapes de calcul de la
chose et on trouve que ces étapes de
calcul sont idiotes
en fait pour juger l'intelligence d'une
structure il faut pas regarder chaque
cas calculs individuels mais du coup il
faut s'intéresser à l'aspect beaucoup
plus macroscopique de la chose d'autres
cherchent à déterminer l'intelligence
monsieur qu'est adrian nous demande si
l'algorithme de glover quin évident
qu'au rythme où quantique est ce qu'il
est capable de trouver une réponse à
avec une fiabilité de 100%
la réponse est non mais en fait j'ai
envie de dire que le risque zéro
n'existe pas et qu'il ya toujours un
risque qu'un ordinateur échoue il peut
toujours avoir un petit bug informatique
quelque part ou encore il peut avoir le
calcul qui est interrompue par une
météorite qui tombera sur la terre et
qui fait tout exploser
bref tout ça pour dire que même au
niveau algorithmique il est souvent
utile de raisonner en termes de
probabilités de succès et en fait à ce
moment là si on analyse rythme dont on
sait que la probabilité de succès est
supérieur à deux tiers disons alors en
fait en répétant cet algorithme un grand
nombre de fois on peut facilement
obtenir très rapidement une fiabilité
qui est de 86 9 9 9 9 %
en effet le nombre de fois qu'il faut
relancer l'algorithme pour avoir un
risque d'erreur inférieure à 10
puissance moins zen qui est vraiment
nouveau très petit con est né un petit
peu grand
c'est égal à peu près à n alors ça peut
paraître anodin ce que je veux dire là
mais en fait une probabilité de 10
puissance moins 100 c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus faible que la probabilité
qu'une météorite tombe sur le terre à
chelles 0,37 nous demande aussi le côté
aléatoire est une partie vraiment
fondamental de l'intelligence ou du
succès d'un algorithme est en fait ça
aussi ça correspond à une question de la
théorie de la complexité absolument
fondamental donc il ya le problème pv
reçus cnp donc thomas vous a parlé dans
une de ses vidéos il ya le problème vécu
paix est égal à paix dont on a parlé
dans les commentaires des vidéos
précédentes
il ya un autre femme qui est bpp égale
paix et donc on pense que penny sur 2 mp
on pense que pays différents de b q p
pour souci que becuwe pays différents de
np mais par contre on pense que paix est
égale un bpa hors jeu pas pouvoir entrer
dans le détail des définitions de tous
ces objets mais en gros si paix est égal
à bp ça veut dire en gros que le hasard
ne sert qu en gros à rien pour pouvoir
accélérer les puissances de calcul de
nos ordinateurs et donc aujourd'hui la
communauté des chercheurs dans le
domaine pense que en effet péter gala
bpp c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de gain
a ajouté un vrai hasard un algorithme
mais bien sûr c'est encore une question
ouverte
clément game le fait remarquer qu'il ya
énormément de recherches aujourd'hui
pour essayer d'ouvrir la black box qui
est l'intelligence artificielle est en
effet il ya pas mal de choses assez
fascinante dont on va parler dans cette
série notamment on peut tout simplement
faire passer une sorte d'irène à nos
intelligences artificielles puisque
l'intelligence artificielle
d'aujourd'hui sont souvent des réseaux
de neurones
donc ça fonctionne pas vraiment comme le
cerveau humain mais ça reste des
neurones qui s'activent qui s'active pas
du coup on peut étudier l'activation des
neurones
lorsque l'on expose un réseau de
neurones artificiels à une image ou un
texte tout ce que vous voulez et du coup
en fait il ya beaucoup d' approche qui
consiste à faire de l'irm mango
d'intelligence artificielle pour voir
comment l'intelligence artificielle
fonctionne et en fait c'est tout ça
finalement c'est très proche de la
manière dont les neuroscientifiques vont
chercher à étudier le fonctionnement du
cerveau bien sûr il ya énormément de
choses que l'on peut comprendre sur le
fonctionnement du cerveau est comme
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut comprendre
sur le fonctionnement d'un réseau de
neurones artificiels et
le titre man fait ça très bien cependant
et j'y reviendrai dans l'épisode suivant
juste parce qu'on est des descriptions
macroscopique de certains aspects de
l'intelligence artificielle ne veut pas
dire qu'on comprend vraiment le
fonctionnement du géographe artificiels
ni même que l'on comprendra un jour
vraiment le comportement de
l'intelligence artificielle est en fait
il ya un très bon argument on verra un
petit peu la semaine prochaine qui a à
voir avec la notion de complexité de
kolmogorov qui nous dit que finalement
vraiment comprendre le fonctionnement
d'un cerveau humain ou de l'intelligence
artificielle sophistiqué tu es en un
certain sens impossible avec eux d'une
certaine manière au bout d'un moment il
vaut mieux considérer tout ça comme des
espèces de black box et avoir des
descriptions macroscopique de ce qui se
passe on oubliera les détails
microscopiques une description de
macroscopique il sera du coup incomplète
plutôt qu'une description microscopique
précise frédéric avait car ça me demande
si j'ai lu le livre de jérémie narby bon
pascal heureusement et non je ne vais
pas lui mais ça me permet de parler de
façon plus générale de choses que l'on a
longtemps considéré comme pas
intelligent et en fait aujourd'hui on
voit que ça beaucoup d'aspects qu'on
pourrait considérer en fait intelligent
typiquement le concept d'intelligence
des plantes pendant longtemps c'est un
truc complètement tabou est de plus en
plus de chercheurs commencent à parler
de l'intelligence des plantes puisque
d'une certaine manière
même si c'est pas un fonctionnement
neuronale comment le cerveau humain à
travers notamment des communications de
produits chimiques les plantes arrive à
anticiper ce qui se passe autour d'eux
de s'adapter à leur environnement voire
de communiquer les unes avec les autres
bref je pense qu'il n'est pas
déraisonnable de parler de
l'intelligence des plantes et de la même
façon si on commence à s'intéresser au
fonctionnement des bactéries des
cellules fonctionnement du système
immunitaire tout ce qui se passe dans le
corps humain
on s'entend que c'est toute une
machinerie extrêmement complexe qui a
d'une certaine manière sa propre
intelligence et j'en profite pour vous
recommander vivement la vidéo de drew
berry où il présente des animations
qu'il a fait du fonctionnement de
certains mécanismes à l'intérieur de nos
cellules notamment par exemple la
retranscription de la vienne qui sont
des mécanismes incroyablement
sophistiqué et c'est difficile quand on
observe ces images ne pas dire qu'il ya
au moins une certaine forme
d'intelligence qui semble émerger de
tout ce mécanisme même si bien sûr cette
intelligence et pas forcément comparable
de l'intelligence humaine
boris elle nous demande même si on peut
pas considérer que dans une structure
une société humaine il ya pas une
certaine intelligence politique émerge
des interactions des différents
individus et là encore il me semble que
la réponse est très clairement oui en
fait il pour vous en convaincre je vous
recommande vivement
ou de monsieur films notamment sur la
veste de laine d' adam smith qui
explique comment dans notre société on
est parvenus à fabriquer des objets
qu'aucun d'entre nous ne savons produire
typiquement une veste de laine en fait
produire une base de laine
il faudrait beaucoup beaucoup eu
d'instruction et tout ça c'est encore
plus le cas quand on voit le degré
d'avancement des mathématiques par
exemple ou tout simplement des
téléphones que vous utilisez tous les
jours la technologie qu'il ya derrière
au repos sur des trucs de mécanique
quantique et rick de technologies de
l'information des concepts de machine de
turing du hardware du software beaucoup
beaucoup de technologie qu'aucun d'entre
nous ne comprenons entièrement en tout
cas moi j'aime beaucoup beaucoup de
choses dans un téléphone portable que je
ne comprends absolument pas et je parle
du téléphone portable pour me donner un
air intelligent mais même dans la
production de la baisse de laignes
énormément de choses que je ne comprends
pas et ça ça me permet de finir sur la
question de mathieu au ruisseau et
d'autres parmi vous qui me reprochent de
n'avoir jamais défini ce qui est l
intelligence et je pense qu'un ultime on
a tous une définition de ce qu'est un
talent donc c'est un peu difficile
encore une fois mais je pense que on
sent plus ou moins karaté gens ça a
quelque chose à voir avec la capacité à
résoudre des problèmes en interagissant
avec le monde qui nous entoure et on
prend à cette définition assez vague qui
est un peu la définition wikipédia
d'ailleurs de l'intelligence on se rend
compte qu'il ya beaucoup de choses dans
notre environnement qui ont une
intelligence que nous n'avons pas nous
alors bien sûr c'est pas satisfaisant
parce que le mot 28 ans rencontrée je
n'ai pas défini mais j'ai envie de dire
david n'a jamais défini le mou structure
et je crois que personne dans les
commentaires de sa vidéo ne lui a
reproché de ne l'avoir jamais défini
tout ça pour dire que au final le sens
précis rigoureux des mots parfois à ce
qu'on cherche à parler de certains
modèles formelle ça peut être utile mais
pour la plupart des mots qu'on a
d'autres langages au quotidien la
définition rigoureuse précise de ces
mots n'est pas utile voire n'est pas
souhaitable voire n'est pas réalisable
quand une fois je brille dans les
commentaires et c'est de définir le mou
structure où le mot chat verrez que
c'est vraiment très difficile et j'ai
envie de dire que c'est vraiment pas
grave pourvu qu'à chaque fois qu'on
utilise ou moque on se rend compte qu'il
est floue et que différentes personnes
utilisent nos différentes manières et ce
qui importe j'ai envie de dire c'est la
manière dont la plupart des gens pensent
le mot n'existe pour insister encore un
peu plus sur ces problèmes de définition
je vous recommande vraiment de lire la
page wikipedia sur l'intelligence où il
ya une excellente discussions sur le
flou autour de ce mot avec notamment
cette citation qui me paraît très très
très pertinente
qui dit que la recherche scientifique
commence très rarement avec des
définitions avec lesquels tout le monde
est d'accord
bien que parfois ça peut il conduire en
particulier je pense que la bonne façon
de s'intéresser à notre les gens ce
n'est pas en commençant par une
définition de l'intelligence mais en
essayant d'abord d'étudier les
différentes interprétations que l'on
pourra avoir de ce mot et en particulier
la pertinence de ces différentes
interprétations pour comprendre le monde
qui nous entoure les cartes vous avez
aimé cette vidéo en fait ce dont on a un
petit peu touchés dans cette vidéo c'est
la notion fondamentale de complexité
algorithmique et je suis de ceux qui
pensent que j'ai contacté algorithme a
des conséquences majeures sur toutes les
sciences voir sur la philosophie
j'en profite pour recommander notamment
l'excellent article écrit par scott
harrison un peu technique c'est en
anglais et tout ça mais c'est un
excellent article qui essaie de
convaincre notamment les philosophes de
s'intéresser à la théorie de la
complexité notamment il ya une réflexion
que je trouve assez amusante sur ce que
signifie que de déterminer le plus grand
nombres premiers connu à ce jour
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour un
nombre d'être le plus grand nombres
premiers comme new york qui me semble
que l'argument de la complexité est tout
à fait pertinent pour donner un sens à
cette phrase
la prochaine fois on va parler de
l'épisode qui est sans doute le plus
important de toute cette série on
parlera de l'argument clé d'alan turing
pour nos papiers de 1950 où il explique
pourquoi
l'intelligence artificielle nécessitera
du machine learning
autrement dit la prochaine fois on va
voir pourquoi est-ce que le machine
learning marche en théorie et comment
que ring a su le prédire dès 1956 dans
une vidéo très importante à semaine
prochaine si vous avez aimé cet épisode
sans celle là qu'elle augmentait le
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
type heure creuse rozon et j'espère tous
vous serez là la prochaine fois c'est ce
phénomène qu'on appelle l'émergence le
fait que des structures complexes puisse
posséder des propriétés macroscopique
qu'on ne retrouve pas dans leurs
constituants de base
on retrouve ces situations d'émergence
aussi bien en physique en biologie mais
aussi en sociologie ou en économie quand
on étudie le comportement des groupes et
c'est le paradoxe de la flèche du temps
avec un ensemble de règles parfaitement
réversible
ce qu'on observe dans un sens comme dans
l'autre du déroulement du temps semble
préférer une certaine évolution
ce qu'on observe macroscopiquement est
statistiquement orienter un état danse
se transforme infiniment plus souvent en
état dilué que le contraire